this guy bivo got new teeth this is the
guy that I was making fun of last time
listen bivo here you know the rules
listen we all know bivo is in Turkey
he's finally got his nashes done listen
behind this remote I've got some sick
you know what I didn't realize when he
blocks his
mouth he actually has the worst hair
I've ever seen in my life it's a it's a
butt crack you know what I mean but
listen 6:00 p.m. English time I'm going
to go live so it be 9:00 p.m. my time
I'm going to go live we're going to do a
reveal but big up the teeth big up UK
Smiles as well listen it's been a it's
been a long week but it's definitely
been worth it I'm um I'm so happy to
finally say get my teeth done and just
enjoy why everyone as well shout out to
Billy shout out to
Sam as well at UK Smiles um yeah it's
been amazing it's been a great
experience they're doing a little UK
tour as well what's going on I'm going
to try and turn up and just show my got
my got my teeth done I'm I'm going put
the reveal it's like appreciation and
just convince people that they know what
they're getting up but yeah 600 p.m.
English
time I'm going to go live and we're
going to reveal my smile but big up to
yourselves much love big up beo as soon
as my teeth have calmed down a bit I'll
start doing eating videos but yeah sorry
for being active but big up to
yourselves chat to you soon as soon as
my as soon as my teeth as soon as my
teeth have calmed down I do some EA
videos for you the weirdest
sentence anyway we saw his teeth uh we
put up a picture of his teeth right
there but they're wild dude when people
get their teeth
done I would be so if I was gonna get my
teeth done which I I wouldn't because
your boy got some nice teeth actually
get some nice Chompers
dude
um a little they're a little crooked but
I you know people get their teeth
whitened or done whitened or or
straightened and they end up looking
like the mask and [__] no dude let me
tell you something okay before you get
your teeth done look in the mirror first
and do
this if you if it's too much like the
mask don't get your [__] teeth
done dude that's the [__] should I
get my teeth done test look in the
mirror and
go if you [__] look dumb doing it of
course you look dumb but if you look
extra dumb like the mask you go you know
what I'm gonna actually cool off and get
my teeth done because man I heard it two
if you get them whitened man my
ex-girlfriend got the zingers dude
that's what they call them they get
zingers where they [__] K dude she
called me she was in Texas she called me
I was I was at home and she was in Texas
she was like I I this is the most pain
I've ever felt in my life I can't even
deal with it and she was crying I was
like dude it's probably fine dude
apparently it gets so painful but yeah
her teeth were fine she didn't need it
to get whitened anyway big up for big up
for her big up to her